so in the wake of the death of George
Florida and the ensuing protests and
riots and with all the craziness that
happened afterwards including the
destruction of statues I wanted to take
a little bit of time before I gave you
some of my analyses on the situation I'm
going to separate this in to a few
videos I'm going to talk about the
toppling of statues I will probably put
out a patron video about watching defeat
but for this first video I want to look
at the narrative how it played out how
it connects very much to symbolic
patterns to our religious impulse to
things like human sacrifice and
catharsis all of these patterns that we
find in human behavior and religion and
in narrative and so hopefully we can
navigate through that and do it in a way
which will not be polarizing but will
help us understand how things are
playing out in terms of storytelling
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so in order to understand what is
happening in terms of the protests we of
course cannot separate it from the the
corona virus pandemic and the narrative
which surrounds this pandemic the way
that it has separated society the way
that especially in North America
there has been some polarizing
discussion much of the problem of the
pandemic of its how serious it was how
bold we can be facing it became
politicized very fast and so it was
difficult to navigate through the facts
and through the scientific analyses
without giving into narrative it was
almost impossible I would say that I
have not heard anybody who has succeeded
because although science can tell you
science can tell you the facts how many
people are dying how many people are
sick how many hospital beds there are
the science cannot tell you what is
acceptable cannot tell you how many
people should die cannot tell you how
cannot help you weigh between sign
between the death of innocence and the
economy the fact that food might become
scarce all of these things are
impossible to weigh and so it fell back
on to the narrative and as we're
watching the identity and the narrative
of Western culture break apart it
inevitably would play out in that term
in in terms of the decisions and the
people complaining about the decisions
so that's the first thing we have to
understand so what ended up happening in
the time of the corona virus is a type
of fasting a type of fasting and a weird
type of separation because of all the
masks all the the confinement everybody
became isolated in their houses stopped
working stopped communing with others it
really became almost like a monastic
fast and strangely enough it happened
during Lent which adds to the
strangeness of it all people ended up
being forced to too fast from sports
which is a big deal it's difficult to
understand how important
it is because sports is a place where we
can non-violently put our identity where
we can non-violently enact the patterns
of aggression and violence related to
identity by identifying with the team by
seeing the other team as the bad guys
and by putting all our emotions into the
simulated conflict we're able to get rid
of a lot of our of the dangerous aspects
of being human let's say but this was
taken away from a lot of people and
everybody everything just got pent up
and things started to to accumulate
within the communities within people and
the death of George Floyd was like a
mastiff which was put in and everything
exploded now one of the thing that's
important to understand at how religious
the narrative ended up being is the
first thing we need to see is the fact
that people watched the death of George
Florida I have to be honest with you I
did not watch it but I would say most
people ended up watching it and what I'm
told is it's very long it lasts you know
almost nine minutes where the policeman
is crushing this man's neck and he is
crying out for his mother it is it's a
horrible scene and so people watched
someone being tortured now we have to
understand the mechanisms of of
catharsis to understand what exactly
that can do to you one of the things
that is meant to happen when you're
looking at something like that narrative
Lee in terms of drama is that is why
tragedies had had such an effect on
human human culture the Greek tragedy
was exactly this thing you're supposed
to watch the hero die the hero go down
and in in this particular case you watch
someone being killed you are watching
them you are identifying with the purse
dying but ultimately what is also what
was also meant to happen was you're
supposed to identify with the person
being killed but let's say as a white
person you're also supposed to identify
with the policeman who is killing George
Floyd right that is the that is the
catharsis moment that because you
identify both with the victim but you're
also identifying with the killer then
that is what is leads to the explosion
the religious explosion which came after
the witnessing of this murder and so it
is almost impossible to understand the
massive protest without understanding
that and so on the one hand you have the
people of African descent who are
portrayed as the victim in the situation
who are being killed but most people the
great the vast majority of people in
North America and in Europe are still
white people and so the event most
people in the protests were white most
people in the rioting were white as well
it seems maybe I don't know about the
statistic but a lot of the images that I
saw were kind of these like young and
Tifa types who were provoking the the
the riot
I don't know but in terms of narrative
it's important to understand that that
as you watch a person getting killed and
as you identify both with the person
being killed and the murderer that is
that which that's what leads to the
catharsis explosion that's what leads to
people going out into the street and
then communing together in mass protest
and the mass protests are really a form
of religious event where you are
communing together you will say there's
mass contrition you are asking
forgiveness you are pouring out your
your sadness of seeing of I how you
identify with the suffering of the one
who is killed but you but also the
sadness and the the the emotion of
identifying also with the killer and so
it is a form of ecstasy it's a form of
religious ecstasy which we saw some
people get it being engaged in if you
look at the manner in which the mayor of
Minneapolis was acting if you look at
the manner in which the mayor of
Minneapolis cried and and did had these
gestures which were extreme in terms of
someone who he didn't know you can
understand that he was he was activating
a form of religious ecstasy as he was
engaging in these acts and that is why
the if you watch the protests if you
watch images of the protests they were
religious in nature they included
kneeling
they included chanting they included
forms of like I said forms of contrition
because what was being called upon in
watching that video was a a form of
religious catharsis which led to all of
this coming together and we need to also
also understand that what had been
happening until then was that everybody
was being pulled apart everybody was
being held apart from each other
everybody was being held in their houses
and now they were coming together and
they were coming together under a
religious guys into a common principle
into a common value and the only common
value that they are allowed let's say to
come in together in two is the value of
openness it is the value of inclusivity
it is the value of the global system it
is the value of you know the only value
left the the value of woke nests of
inclusivity as the principle the only
principle which can unite us and so
usually principles of unity are
exclusive exclusionary right deep what
unites your family together is also what
separates you from other families what
unites your country your knit your
nation your his
your soccer club or whatever it is that
unites people together also has an
exclusionary aspect to it but the last
religion we could call it the religion
of the of the end is a religion of
inclusion it is a religion in which the
only value which brings us together is
to include everything and we can see it
in in the speeches of those who embrace
that type of thinking Justin Trudeau
comes to mind especially because he
really has been a prophet of this type
of thinking where he says things that
would know when he talks about how
diversity is our only value our only
value is diversity we are a post
nationalist nation all of this is the
last value this last value possible and
so and what it does is it creates also a
radical exclusion now that is very
important the only sin left is the sin
of exclusion and it is a sin which is
unforgivable
it is a sin which cannot be you know
that you can any and there's a there's a
strange contradiction in there come on
the one hand all the people who are
meant who are supposed to identify with
the Chauvin the chauvinistic Chauvet are
supposed to understand that they have
this sin it becomes the reason why they
are able to commune with all of each
other but ultimately it is an
unforgivable sin and it is a it is the
only thing which will exclude and so the
only way that you cannot be excluded is
by ramping up the acts which show that
you are inclusive right all the virtue
signaling we saw all the oh the desire
to to take the sins onto your back in
order to then at least be safe inside so
that although you cannot be forgiven you
nonetheless are able to be inside the
inclusive group by doing that and then
all then by criticizing and by
criticizing all those that aren't as
being the ultimate outsider the only
outsider is the one who won't
include everything and the final part of
this the final part which really does
make it into a religious of religion of
wellness is of course the human
sacrifice now some people will say that
I'm being hyperbolic in saying that
human sacrifice was involved in this
story but I have to tell you that there
it is it is clearly there within the
very narrative that the people who are
engaging in this are proposing
themselves now of course the first human
sacrifice was George Floyd he was of
course the first person to be sacrificed
unwillingly for the this communion of
inclusion but the very coming together
the very act of communion became a form
of human sacrifice now like I said it is
within their own narrative that it is so
because we saw that because of the
coronavirus what we were told is that if
you come together if you come and meet
in groups if you go to church if you go
to your work you know if you're if you
go to parties if you invite people to
your house all of these things is
killing people you are killing people if
you engage in this and of course the the
ultimate version of that was when we saw
that that the people who were protesting
the lockdown they were telling they were
presenting them as being completely
insensitive completely selfish because
here they are killing their grandmothers
and grandfathers in order just so that
they can start the economy again and so
now the very same people who said that
then engaged in the very act that they
decry they came together and they joined
together in communion massive massive
communion you know tens of thousands of
people meeting together in these
protests and they understood even if
secretly that they were doing what they
said not to do but they were willing to
accept it and you can see that in
the in the letter that the medical these
medical people signed in order to say
that they they encourage the protest you
know that they encourage the fact that
people protest racism because racism is
worse than the coronavirus and you can
understand it so it's it is ends up
being a hierarchy of values the highest
value the transcendent value is the
value of inclusion and you are allowed
to sacrifice others for that value it is
it is considered a noble act to
sacrifice others now I'm not even saying
whether or not it is actually
sacrificing people that's not the point
the point is to see within their very
own religious narrative how within that
narrative that is what they're doing
within their own story they are
sacrificing others in order to commune
in the name of their highest principle
so that really cinches it and it really
cinches it in terms of a new religion
now I want to call out I want to call
out to all of the the new atheist all of
the Steven Pinker types all of these
these types of people who for the past
generation has been have been decrying
religion in terms of the belief in the
Supreme Being the belief in the
afterlife and all of these things now
look around you the pattern is playing
out no matter what it is playing out
half Hazzard Lee because it is happening
in a manner which is not which is not
turned towards the highest highest thing
right and because of that it's going to
play out in all kinds of chaotic ways
and I dare I say in dangerous ways but
it is a religion nonetheless and what it
shows is that we have these patterns in
us we have these patterns probe we are
made as religious beings if you try to
remove religion it is going to come back
it might not come back the way you want
it to come back and it might come back
in ways which are scary and dangerous
and so we need to be we need to be very
attentive to that and to remember why we
have the stories we have why the story
of Christ is meant to is meant to do
something similar than what we saw when
we saw George Florida being killed we
are also supported support supposed to
identify with Christ supposed to
identify with his killers but in that
identification and in that coming
together we are not left with a dead end
we are not left in with a dead end of
infinite contrition and infinite guilt
that we pile upon our shoulders it is
meant to bring us into a type of freedom
and not a not a not an eternal
recurrence of of contrition that you can
never get out of and so hopefully that
is going to help you understand a little
bit of what is happening and in my net
in my other videos I will also look at
some of the the acts that we've seen the
pulling down the statues the washing of
feet and other similar things and so I
hope this was helpful everybody and I'll
talk to you very soon